good morning Hank it's Tuesday so our
dad is a documentary filmmaker and when
we were growing up he worked on movies
about everything from water in Florida
to education in Alaska and I guess
there's a case to be made that we
followed in his footsteps by creating
non-fiction video except I don't really
think of like this as a documentary this
is more you know like very short
podcasts featuring facial expressions
which is a genre of nonfiction video
that is far less expensive and time
consuming than documentaries and also
requires less talent for visual
storytelling which is great because even
after more than ten years I'm still
pretty bad at editing video but one
thing I did inherit from dad is a really
deep love for documentary films like
Hank as you know my dream job has always
been you know what I'm about to date
myself but there used to be this widely
adopted technology called a cable
television basically you would pay a
monthly fee in exchange for access to
lots of video content so it was sort of
like Netflix except for some reason you
still had to watch advertisements it was
a weird time but anyway there were these
cable stations that just showed old
movies all day like one of them was
called Turner Classic Movies and before
the movie started there would always be
this person who would introduce the
movie to you and talk about some
historical context and who the stars
were now it occurs to me in retrospect
that the introducer probably existed
mostly to make the movie longer like if
you could stretch a 90-minute movie into
a hundred twenty minutes of content then
you could add eight minutes of
advertising but when I was a kid that
was my dream job to be an introducer but
not of regular movies of documentaries
these days documentaries are a lot
easier to discover than they were when I
was a kid Netflix for instance has an
excellent and extensive library but
still many of my favorite documentaries
aren't on Netflix like I'm thinking of
the 7up series where a filmmaker has
checked in every seven years with a
group of people since they were kids in
the 1960s or herb and Dorothy a movie
about a postal worker and a librarian
living in New York City who became two
of the world's leading art collectors or
the classic complaints of a dutiful
daughter a gut-wrenching and sometimes
hilarious movie about a woman whose
mother has Alzheimer's for slavery by
another name a movie about the failures
of Reconstruction and the post-civil war
United States there are so many great
documentaries and so few of them ever
find a broad audience but as a kid my
favorite genre of documentary was the
nature documentary where you can see
animals in the wild like fighting to
survive I love nature docks because they
felt like a glimpse into a world with
Aldus I mean they almost never include
humans in the frame and there's
something magical about that but of
course in real life humans can't be
separated from nature I mean we're
currently nature's most important
species and the choices were making
affect every other species on earth and
that's what I love so much about the
movie Katey and why I wanted us to help
in its distribution
Kevi uses all the conventions of the
nature documentary you get the beautiful
cinematography the fight scenes the
plucky underdog is struggling to survive
the parents caring for babies but it
doesn't exclude humans from the story
instead we see the connecting points
between a city and its people and its
cats it is a nature documentary that
acknowledges that humans are part of
nature and it shows that life for cats
is sometimes tender and sometimes cold
and always unpredictable as it is for
humans now I know that Kenny is
currently only available via purchase or
YouTube read and that makes it
inaccessible to a lot of you one of the
big challenges with documentaries is
that it's really hard to fund them on
advertising revenue alone which is why
so few of them are available on free
streaming services at least legally but
regardless if you do have a chance to
see it someday I really hope you do it's
a wonderful movie while I'm fulfilling
my dream of being an introducer to other
recommendations if you live in the
United States PBS has some excellent
documentaries that are actually
available for free also wherever you
live there is a free an ongoing
documentary project that you might enjoy
called the road to nerdfighteria about
how different people found this little
corner of the internet and what it means
to them they're still accepting
submissions and it's a really wonderful
series links in the doobly-doo below
Hank I will see you on Friday and screen
Hank I'll actually won't see you on
Friday that was misleading and I
apologize but I'm going to be taking
like a week or possibly two weeks away
from the internet to focus on some
writing things but there will be a video
next Tuesday it's just that I recorded
it in advance okay check out ket again
the road to nerdfighteria bye